[Música]
es un acontecimiento que los habitantes
de la isla de grúa no se perderían por
nada del mundo el campeonato mundial de
remo
otra prueba productiva
con un vals bailado por los marineros
desde tiempos inmemoriables un gesto
actualizado a través de esta competición
deportiva
patrimonio vivo de la isla el remo es
practicado con pasión por todas las
generaciones
originalmente el remo era un privilegio
de los pescadores de la isla
hoy
y una técnica ancestral que les permitía
navegar frente a la isla de wright y
pescar con caña
[Aplausos]
desde entonces la pesca tradicional ha
desaparecido pero el remo sigue siendo
practicado por los jóvenes de la isla
como estos dos hermanos
un día del comienzo del campeonato
mundial están perfeccionando su técnica
el secreto está en un gesto amplio y
regular acción
estás presionando demasiado de un lado
ahora estamos girando con tu mano
derecha tu mano derecha aquí arriba eso
ahora voltea y no puedo seguir al
principio es un poco difícil pero una
vez que uno la coge avanza bien
el joven ha estado practicando este
gesto casi todos los días durante cuatro
años
las olas que hacen el movimiento
participa en el campeonato por cuarta
vez por eso desde hace un mes se entrena
con un objetivo superar su tercer puesto
del año pasado
sientes un poco de presión no no no
estoy participando para ser el primero
pero es para divertirme
no solo los isleños se interesan por el
remo
esta joven de brest también quiere
participar en la competencia pero para
ello tiene que encontrar el ritmo
adecuado
oh dios mío es monstruoso wow
este es enorme es la que usa todo el
mundo tiene que soplar pero creo que es
el que usábamos en el pequeño en el mar
está bueno si aún no has hecho nada
tiene alguna posibilidad no voy a dar la
clasificación pero sería más hacia el
final por ahora pero hay que ver los
otros competidores un poco gracias por
la confianza pero solo puedes mejorar
tienes un gran margen de progreso
[Música]
la competencia está a punto de comenzar
o fue la joven de brest espera
impaciente su turno para registrarse
no
el que sale primero axel quien ha
entrenado todo el invierno es el niño de
la isla evidentemente el tiempo que
debes y carla mando es proporcional al
tiempo que ya no dedica a estudiar
su madre está en primera fila para
apoyarlo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para acceder la decepción es inmensa con
su tiempo llega en tercer lugar a la
clasificación provisional de juniors si
quiere ganar el título tendrá que ir
mucho más rápido mañana mira bien hacia
atrás y apuntas a la entrada y estarás
en la recta en el menor tiempo posible
y luego lo das todo al final ahora le
toca a usted dar el paso
en comparación con su oponente mucho más
experimentada la joven se enfrenta a un
gran desafío remo derecho 23 golpes
demás y se lanza contra su oponente
en público y el reloj
[Aplausos]
con 2 minutos 55 segundos la aureola de
brest llega novena en la categoría
femenina
al día siguiente axel hizo un sprint e
increíble y terminó según la
clasificación
[Aplausos]
después de esos dos días de feroz
competencia el campeonato ha terminado
por un momento los habitantes de la isla
de grúa habrán vivido al ritmo del remo
al ritmo de un vals de dos tiempos
[Música]